[Musique]
l'événement c'est bien le tgvair il
relie paris à lyon en 2h40 22 septembre
1981 il ya tout juste 40 ans les
français découvrent le train le plus
rapide du monde sur rail le tgv couleur
orange à plus de 270 kilomètres heure il
avale les kilomètres entre paris et lyon
le début d'un long succès pour cette
fierté de l'industrie française
après le paris-lyon le tgv atlantique en
1989 nantes n'est plus qu'à 2 heures de
paris le mans à 55 minutes un tgv encore
plus moderne plus rapide 300 km/heure et
summum du confort il y à même le
téléphone à bord
trois ans plus tard en 1992 et pour la
première fois le tgv s'exporte à
l'étranger
direction l'espagne madrid n'est plus
qu'à 2 heures 45 de séville contre 7
heures auparavant ne l'appelez plus tgv
mais avait eu pour alta velocidad
espagnol à la veille de la reine fait
l'équivalent de la sncf ressemble bien
sûr au tgv atlantique mais l'aménagement
intérieur des voitures a été amélioré
avec plus d espace pour les passagers
une climatisation adaptées au climat
espagnols et des moniteurs vidéo un peu
partout
en 2000 le train le plus rapide du monde
sur rails c'est toujours lui cette année
là le tgv quitte l'europe en route pour
les états unis avec la ligne boston new
york washington
accueillis par des hôtesses en uniforme
les voyageurs sont installés dans de
larges sièges équipés de prises
électriques pour les ordinateurs le prix
du voyage n'est pas donné 850 francs
pour le trajet boston new york et 1000
francs pour le parcours new york
washington et c'est pas fini la
technologie du tgv continue de
s'exporter après l'europe et les états
unis l'asie en 2004 alstom et à la
construction du caté x le tgv sud coréen
entre séoul et pusan à l'intérieur c'est
le futur les sièges pivote seulement 12
des 46 ont été réalisées en france les
12 premières et puis les 34 autres ont
été réalisés en corée par nos
partenaires convient c'est même train en
plus longue et avec quelques
particularités pour respecter des
conditions d'environnement les longs
tunnels sur le tracé coréen en 2018 le
tgv c'est aussi exporté en afrique au
maroc aujourd'hui il reste toujours le
train le plus rapide du monde sur rails
le voilà au bout de la ligne droite
effectivement c c'est toi c'est sur une
fusée sur terre dernier record en date
en 2007 il s'élançait à plus de 574 km
heure en france performance encore
inégalée aujourd'hui
[Musique]